[Music]
the ending of ursula k le guin's sixth
earth sea novel the other wind the
resolution of the three problems or
crises that book begins with
and the culmination of the entire earth
c series
takes place
through an undoing of one of the central
features of that narrative land that we
saw
from the very beginning with a wizard of
earth sea and then running through the
other works as well and everything kind
of gets brought to
a closure point but there's also
the possibility of new things
still happening
and this has to do with pulling down
the wall of stones that separates off as
originally thought the dry land of the
dead
from the world of the living but it
turns out that this wall of stones is
also a demarcation point for something
else
and this emerges in the discussions of
the agreement the division the verdurnan
that was made between human beings and
dragons and how it was violated
by some of the archipelagon
humans who used magic who used the
language of the making
to do something and so
there's this discussion that that goes
on
and
here we go
this is a um
a talk that's given by the name or the
master namer i say what i have half
learned half guest not from village
tales but from the most
ancient records in the isolate tower so
this is on rock a thousand years before
the first kings of enlar there were men
in aya and solea the first and the
greatest of the mages the rune makers it
was they who learned to write the
language of the making they made the
runes which the dragons never learned
they taught us to give each soul its
true name which is its truth itself and
with this power they granted to those
who bear their true name life beyond
the body's death so they they did
something
new they didn't just take the language
that the dragons began with actually all
all beings all rational beings human and
dragon alike who were originally one
race
began with
they
innovated they
wrote them down they assigned to
individual human beings or discovered
for human beings their true names and
those true names gave them the
possibility
of something
sepal then the pelnish wizard says life
immortal
and so the idea here is
life immortal in what sense in a dreary
deprived existence no life immortal
in a beautiful
land a great land of rivers and
mountains and beautiful cities
where there is no suffering or pain
where the self endures
unchanged unchanging forever that is the
dream of the ancient law of palm now
notice what he's saying it's not just
that the land is eternal
individual beings have this beautiful
painless existence
where they can continue on after they
have died in the body
sounds kind of heavenly doesn't it
now in doing so
the ancient mages
did something that was not just
you might say on the side of violation a
direct violation of the division and the
agreement
that was made between the peoples
and so the summoner says where is that
land and irian says on the other wind
which is our realm are the realm of the
dragons she says uh do you think our
realm is only a few rocks at the edges
of your rich islands you own the earth
you own the sea we are the fire of
sunlight we fly the wind
you were not content with your share you
wanted not only your cares but our
freedom you wanted the wind and here's
where she says something really
important by the spells and wizardries
of those oathbreakers you stole half our
realm from us walled it away from life
and light so you could live there
forever now was it exactly half we don't
know it doesn't matter a significant
portion of what was to be the dragons
was taken
by these mages and what did they do
they created a wall that
living beings including dragons
could not pass
so the patterner continues the story and
says
the ancients saw the dragon's realm was
not of the body only that they could fly
outside of time it may be envying that
freedom they followed the dragon's way
into the west beyond the west they
claimed part of that realm as their own
a timeless realm where the self might be
forever but not in the body as the
dragons were so the dragons exist in
this timeless realm the other wind
in their bodies because they are
magic itself they are the language of
the making
only in spirit could men be there he
continues so they made a wall which no
living body could cross
neither man nor dragon for they feared
the anger of the dragons so they set up
a kind of defensive bull work to keep
the dragons out
their arts of naming laid a great net of
spells upon all the western lands so
that when the people of the islands die
they would come to the west beyond the
west and live there in the spirit
forever
so they're taking part of this wonderful
existence
and claiming it for their own setting up
this wall that will keep the dragons out
you might say creating a funnel that
will take the souls or spirits of those
who die to there
and then things go wrong and why well we
don't know
there is a proverb here that said irian
says greed puts out the sun these are
colessene's words
and what does end up happening as the
wall was built and the spell laid
the wind ceased to blow
within the wall the sea withdrew so
these
important
fundamental elements
are not being lost
but are being
you could say
reduced into a different state there is
no wind within the dry land it is the
dry land because there is no sea
there anymore
and what else happens the mountains of
sunrise became the mountains of the
night the mountains that are known as
pain
those who died came to a dark land
a dry land
and leba lebanon says i've walked in
that land i do not fear death but i fear
it and we should remind ourselves of
some of the features of the dry land
as we saw in
some of the earlier novels
it is not a good place and the people
who exist there exist as names and as
shadows but that's it not existing in
their full self
as we've seen lovers pass each other by
without looking at each other parents
and children don't pay attention there
are indeed cities but nothing actually
happens within the cities the dead are
just
there
and so this now we can see
as not just oh a problematic aspect of
existence but something that was
created
by human beings
and the mistake is is theirs so
what has to be done
in order to fix this the dry land has to
be undone and returned back to
what it was and this is going to require
pulling down the wall of stones it also
requires alder to be taken as a
sort of guide and what we find is that
while they're there in the imminent
grove alder actually is on the verge of
death he's talking with
the other wizards and he says
well the summoner says the souls of the
dead come reaching now across the wall
yearning back into life and alder says
no no no it's not life they want it's
death to be one with the earth again
to rejoin it they all looked at him but
he hardly knew it his awareness was half
with them
half in the dry land the grass beneath
his feet was green and sunlit was dead
and dim the leaves of the trees trembled
above him in the low stone wall lay only
a little distance from him down the dark
wall the dark hill of them all he saw
only to hanu who could not see here
clearly but he knew her
and he says they built it but they
cannot unbuild it will you help me
tahanu and she says i will hara he's
dying
and we find out that the summoner brings
him back into life and you know when
asked about it he said well i could do
it and
then he says i actually shouldn't have
done it they discuss a little bit more
and decide that alder is going to have
to be
their guide
why
so
gamble says he's no guide patterner a
village mender and onyx says alder has
wisdom but in his hands not in his heart
his head he follows his heart
certainly he doesn't seek to lead us all
yet he was chosen from among us all who
chose him sepal asked softly and the
patterner says
the dead
the dead have chosen him that's why he's
having these dreams
and so
what is all they're going to do
we find that he tells
tahanu
she asks him what what do we have to do
hara and he says we have to mend the
world
he smiled because his heart had grown
light at last we have to break the wall
and hanu says can they help us she's
gesturing at the dead and he says
no
but maybe others can and so he
and tahanu first start pulling away
at the rocks and then
the others
follow him
and they arrive by
different paths we find
that the patterner says now it changes
and he walked away from them into the
darkness under the trees the summoner
the doorkeeper and seppl rose and
followed him quick and silent gamblin
onyx followed more slowly after them so
the all the wizards are going off to
help out with the wall lebanon stood up
he took a few steps after the others
hesitated and hurried across the glade
to the low house of stone and sod and
here he talks to the dragon irian will
you take me with you and she says come
then come quick and took his hand her
hand burned like a coal of fire as she
lifted him
into the other wind so they're taking
two different paths to get there the
wizards are following alder erien is
taking lebanon with her on the other
wind because the other wind goes to the
stone wall as well
and
while they're there they're all taking
part in pulling the stone wall apart we
get descriptions of this alder could
scarcely move the great stone his hands
were on but the summoner was beside him
stooping with his shoulder against it
and said now together they pushed it
till it over bounced and dropped down
with that same heavy final thump on the
far side of the wall
tahanu was wrenching at the stones
alder saw his own hands cast shadows for
an instance from a red gleam or irian as
he had seen her first a great dragon
shape had let out her fiery breath as
she struggled to move a boulder from the
lowest rank of stones deep set in the
earth her talon struck sparks in her
thorn back arch in the rock world
ponderously
free breaching the wall entirely in that
place so they're all using all that they
have the entire company dragon
archipelagon and karg because of course
the patterner is a carg and
they bring down the wall of stones
together
what is the result of this
well
we read there was a vast soft cry
among the shadows on the other side
like the sound of a sea on a hollow
shore
their darkness surged up against the
wall but alder looked up and saw it was
no longer dark
the dry land is now being restored
light
moved in that sky where the stars had
never moved
quick sparks of fire far in the dark
west
then we hear tahanu saying collecting
he looked at her she was gazing upward
westward she had no eye for earth we'll
come back to her in a moment
from among the hosts of the dead a few
here and there like tahanu rose up
flickering into dragons and mounted on
the wind so the human dead some of them
become dragons they'd be they have the
original unity restored most came
forward afoot they were not pressing not
crying out now but walking with
unhurried certainty toward the fallen
places in the wall great multitudes of
men and women who as they came to the
broken wall did not hesitate but stepped
across it and were gone
a wisp of dust a breath that's shown an
instant in the ever brightening light
they are returning back to
the earth
and perhaps they will be reincarnated
like the cogs are perhaps they will just
simply
regain their place
what we find is that alder
sees his wife again
and is rejoined with her
lily he said she saw him and smiled and
held her outer hand to him he took her
hand and they crossed together
into the sunlight
all right do they turn to dust we don't
know
leguin doesn't tell us
now we should talk about tehanu
and this really brings together a number
of different themes
we should also remember too that
orimerian is going to
fly off
onto the other wind but the patterner
who has fallen in love with her hopes
that she will come back to him someday
but what we find with tahanu the maimed
abused child who has been raised as a
foster by
the couple of tahanu and ged
becoming her mother first gad becoming
her father later is that
she becomes the dragon that she is
she reached up her arms
fire ran along her hands her arms into
her hair into her face and body flamed
up into great wings above her head
and lifted her into the air a creature
all fire blazing
beautiful
she cried out aloud a clear
worldless
wordless cry
she felt flew high headlong fast up into
the sky where the light was growing and
a white wind had erased the unmeaning
stars
and
what we find is that the
you know this isn't the the very last of
her
uh the patterner tells tenor in her
language they are both cards
my lady i saw tahanu she flies golden
on the other wind
and then we have a very
touching moment one that is expressed in
a single set of words but is
very deep tenor glanced up at him his
face was white and worn but there was a
shadow of glory in his eyes
she struggled
and then said speaking roughly and
almost inaudibly just one word
whole
he nodded
she stroked alder's hand the mender's
hand fine skillful tears came into her
eyes
is she crying for the loss of alder is
she crying for the loss of
tahanu or is she crying
out of a sort of joy
whole that that word tahanu was
starved beaten
raped abused in so many ways
by her parents and the people they
traveled with thrown living into a fire
where her body was damaged
destroying one half of her face and one
of her hands
and she faced all of the eprobrium that
goes along with that in a
you could say unenlightened society
over and over again in the book to hanu
these people try to get at her again
until finally they're they're taken out
of the picture through the king's
justice and geds intervention as well
and so she has lived a tough life
she's able to be whole again
whole is she never
truly was whole as a grown adult
whole as the dragon that she is
as well
and this is something that
you could say
any good parent
wants for
their children especially if the
children have
encountered trauma setbacks
hurts damage to be restored to
wholeness
and this is the way that it can happen
for tahanu to be
a dragon
we find at the very end of this tahani
her tenor has returned to gant
and is meeting up with ged her husband
and she tells him the story of things
and then there's
a point where he says
and tahanu a silence she went out of the
house when i came out she was gone
oswar saw her in the sunrise on the
other wind
and afterwards uh ged says look there
tenar she looked where he was looking
into the dim gulf of air
above the western sea
if she comes she'll come from there he
said and if she doesn't come
she is there
she nodded i know her eyes were full of
tears
lebanon sang me a song on the ship when
we were going back to havnor she could
not sing she whispered the words
oh my joy be free.
and
again this is emblematic of what it is
that a good parent wants for
their children to be free
and that may mean being somewhere else
not having contact
but knowing that
their existence is a good one a better
one
one that is suited to them the good
parent can
feel joy in that while feeling sorrow
and this is
where the book ends and where the
tales of earth see
come to
a close
you